[sparse electronic music]
♫
You say you're sorry
and you're leaving
Don't think we'll work out
and it's just a feeling
I say hey baby,
don't you worry
Just want you happy
and if it's not me, then
You can go on your way
I'd never force you to stay
But I'm so far from okay (yeah)
(Oh oh) Let's be alone together
Oh, can we be alone together?
You can go off on your own
I'll love you whether
I'm all alone
But we're alone together
You tell yourself
this is the right thing
Oh yes, you miss me
and you're so damn lonely
But you don't come back in the morning
I fall asleep
dreaming that you hold me
You don't reach out again
And I'm just here wondering
How long were you pretending?
(Oh oh) Let's be alone together
Oh, can we be alone together?
You can go off on your own
I'll love you whether
I'm all alone
But we're alone together
(Oh oh) Let's be alone together
Oh, can we be alone together?
You can go off on your own
I'll love you whether
I'm all alone
But we're alone together
[pause]
(Oh oh) Let's be alone together
Oh, can we be alone together?
You can go off on your own
I'll love you whether
I'm all alone
But we're alone together
(Oh oh) Let's be alone together
Oh, can we be alone together?
You can go off on your own
I'll love you whether
I'm all alone
But we're alone together